You would agree that it could be interesting...
...to visit the actual place where your favorite movies or books are based.
This time, how about watching the movie "The Beach" starring Leonardo di Caprio?
Then, fly to Phuket in Thailand.
It only takes 45 minutes by speedboat or 90 minutes by ferry from Phuket...
...to reach the picture postcard islands of Phi Phi.
The islands seem to grow out of the sea like a big fortress...
...when you approach them by boat.
You will fall in love with this place...
...because it is the perfect paradise where you can enjoy dream beaches,...
...fantastic rock formations and a multicolored marine life.
Joining cruise day trips to nearby islands is a must.
One of the islands you will visit...
...provided the actual background that was often filmed in the movie,...
...but sadly the island is uninhabited, so you are not allowed to stay there.